thirty one-year-old ahead face Duke is a
Syrian activist who first came to the
u.s. in 2015 to give a talk about the
situation back home in 2011 she'd taken
to the streets in her home city of
Aleppo to demand a more inclusive
government started in Aleppo we started
really like few people and then it
started to be like hundreds and then
thousands of thousands but what started
as a protest movement quickly turned to
a civil war as her family fled to Turkey
she stayed behind volunteering in a
hospital you see like you see sometimes
people are dying in front of your eyes
you can do anything to to them you see
how families are grieving their children
until the hospital like so much of her
hometown was destroyed by government
bombs I just I left working in medical
field I I stopped I couldn't see anyone
abroad worldwide some 14 million Syrians
have been displaced by the ongoing war
indiscriminate bombings continue to
claimed the lives of children and
civilians Syrians like phos Duke who've
been residing in the US since 2016 have
been granted temporary protective status
that means they can work legally and for
a further 18 months at least won't face
deportation but those who work with
refugees say so many more need help
other Syrians who came even hours later
after that deadline are left without
that protection and left in a really
insecure position and really uncertain
about what's going to happen next the
snuke has mixed feelings about staying
as she can't leave the country to visit
family or help people back home and you
should be grateful and you should feel
like you are the lucky person to be here
while your people are under the
bombardment and their daily life
ultimately she wants to go home we are
going back when this crazy regime stop
killing us but so far no one has been
able or willing to protect them
Christians salumi algae's
era New York